Pokemon go you had your phone out
earlier Justin you're playing it uh
everyone ice like I see people playing
this game frequently about and it's all
the rage what's the deal why is it so
popular and it's crazy how popular it is
I expected this to catch on in a big way
ingress the developers previous game was
another augmented reality game it has
tens of thousands of players all over
the world and it still does it still a
phenomenon but not in the way the
Pokemon was and I knew that it would
catch on big like Israel ingress was
able to capture that that kind of
passion when you put a Pokemon skin of
course it's gonna get big but every day
I'm sitting on the train and I see
people playing when people walk by me at
a coffee shop they're talking about
catching pokemon it's that's madness to
me like I didn't think it would expand
that far and these people are all 14
year old children correct it's everybody
like Randy is anything like I'm 58
yesterday congratulations I just went
out to lunch and someone had dropped
some lures at a pokey stop and I saw all
these people like literally just
standing around outside just on their
phone doing this and you know we sort of
like locked eyes and just went yeah I
know what you're doing well what's up
yeah but but you know I think I think
the reason is yes you know there's a lot
of people who love poker especially you
know like way back in the 90s when you
know when the first came out but i think
the you know the thing that's really
sort of help sort of escalate this is a
couple of things one it's free and two
it's not actually much of a game you
know there's not a huge sort of barrier
of entry if you're not like the gamer to
actually get into this you know like
isn't the much the most that you really
do is you know swipe up on your on your
screen to try and catch pokemon and the
rest of it is social the rest of it is
exploring you know a real world with
Pokemon insert it into it and you know
trying to catch all the you know 151 I
think that are in their rights original
its just oh gee only the original
Pokemon yeah so the whole social
collecting aspect of this is you know I
think the thing that's really made it
pop and it just helps that it's it's not
that great a game now when you say the
social collecting aspects there's
there's two things there's two distinct
things there I think what is personal
collecting like I
wanted my collection yet bigger I want
to get a specific Pokemon I you know
want to build my collection but then
there's the social aspect how does that
manifest for you are you coming in and
being like justin whats up its mizzou
bad or are you comparing this online
somehow how's that working yeah not with
Zubat so I mean you Kristen 10 anyway
don't do bad stuff so so the game does a
really really bad job of actually a
telling you you know how to what to do
and what to do and be making you feel
like you're part of a greater community
outside of gym battles right so I guess
all of the all of the social aspect of
it has been yeah like you know I come
into work I you know I talked to Justin
and go hey you know guess what i call it
last night or how do you do this you
know that type of things so you know
like wouldn't within itself it's not a
very well set up social game I'm yet to
dig into sort of like gym battles though
which i think is you know where most of
that sort of social aspect actually lies
yeah gym battles are I think really
interesting i have not had any success
because every time i go to a gym i get
this bug where oh yeah the trainer is
unbeatable which is really annoying but
like ideal of the idea bug pokemon it's
got like the Scarab thing sticking out
the head yeah it's unbeatable unbeatable
it's like shaped like a method as an
amazing stuff but the gym battles are
the thing I think that as they expand it
will bring people together around their
community because that's how ingress was
was put together that you had three
distinct teams and Pokemon go you have
three distinct teams our battle lines in
the office are clearly drawn around the
teams we've chosen right now we're still
friendly like because there isn't that
competitive aspect but I think
eventually that is a thing that will
divide us as a country as a nation
there's a world as a world and that
Justin you always you know a bit more
about ingress there was a narrative as
well right like with with the teams and
how you're supposed to like you know try
and take over each others you know basis
and all that sort of stuff right yeah
you had these areas that were set up
around different cities and depending on
which team took it that would actually
affect the narrative and of course
there's nothing built like that into
pokemon right now but if they introduce
things like that if they say like if
Team Red controls most of San Francisco
maybe team rocket will come in although
if there is some kind of narrative
aspect like that would I hope
help push things along a little bit but
I mean at this point what more push does
it need I mean I guess you know we're
still in the first week of release as
long as dill yeah it's totally the
honeymoon phase I mean I you know you're
still seeing people play it regularly
you're discussing it with people by the
way Justin what is your team of choice
I'm team valor which is to read if you
valor all the way all right good to know
I don't even know if it's Ginza together
so there's team it there's the blue team
which is team mystic and team at the
yellow team which is team instinct die
if I'm not mistaken that was Peter Brown
hollering for Team mystic somewhere
Serrano another realm mr. India oh it's
very comfy sounds like Peter Brown in
the microphone he sounds like to mystic
good this is my first time least he's
not team instinct this is we're talking
about ingress right and this is nigh
antics as I then developers previous
game quite successful but still a cult
phenomenon a small phenomenon by any
measure this on the other hand you know
wildly exceeding expectations I I
imagine as we talked about earlier but
at the same time not being much of a
game so is that is is this a kind of
game that people will start having this
discussion about I mean is this even a
game as it does do people even still
have that discussion or has it just sort
of tapped into like hey here's a cool
way I can use my pocket computer to go
to places and sort of connect with folks
yeah i think in them in a mobile world
right i think they have these metrics
are the people who measure these things
you know they always like to look at
apps what they do after 70 days after 30
days and after 90 days and then that's
when they know if something's gonna be a
long term hit or not right and so I
think we're still to come to seven days
like released in I think the North
America and Australia New Zealand the
only official place is at right so we're
still yet to come to its first week
anniversary it looks to be holding up
pretty well right now I mean right now
daily active users means nothing it has
not been around long enough for that to
actually be an important metric but the
amount of time people are spending into
the game is like I think on average 43
minutes a day and then that's your one
battery charge basically for a day and
that's after that it crashes yeah so
you'll see what we will see what happens
after 30 days but you know I think
niantic has already talked about updates
right so things to try and keep the
commute
in there and I think the next big one
that they're talking about is the
ability to actually trade which is kind
of a big thing not to have at launch for
a Pokemon title so I don't think they've
actually David Wright like when they're
hoping to do that but when that does
come in then yeah I think that really
amplifies the social aspect we're
talking about before right because now I
can say that Justin hey I've got this
thing I've got extras of this let's
trade what do you have that type of
thing and in terms of the regional map I
was talking with you Justin earlier and
you were saying that San Francisco is
just lousy with zoo bats but that's not
necessarily like the case in other
regions do you see that you know as you
sort of read about folks experiences
playing do you see that regional
distribution being sort of a force to
fuel this trading or I think the
regional aspect could be really
fascinating like I don't think they'll
have one point in the world because it's
such a big game if you had one point of
the world which is the only place to
catch a Pokemon that would be crazy but
what if they spread out like the
legendaries we don't know anything about
how to get the are though our mascot
birds for each of our teams what if
those are just spread out throughout the
entire world and you do have to kind of
make a pilgrimage to a specific spot and
maybe catch them as a group or as a team
like that would be a really interesting
thing to to increase that community
while also giving you a really fun thing
to do as a group and get together around
finish him you to just hatches out of a
two-kilometer you have to 150 kilometers
50 kilometers 40 I would never do that
so no meu to know me too for me alas uh
alright what we've talked about there's
you know it's still the first week there
was a security issue that was addressed
on iOS but they're still bugs they're
still crashes they're still the server
struggling to handle the massive load of
people playing do you feel like these
are kinks that are going to be worked
out or is this kind of like a a warning
sign of like wow maybe they didn't
really know what they were getting into
well it seems like most of the bugs so
far you can put down to server load
right so it has been a crazy week for
this game right and i think the antic
has gone on the record saying they
expected it to be big but not this huge
so obviously when a company like that it
is caught by surprise then you know the
servers are going to fall down alright
so you know I'm still playing and still
experiencing a lot of free
you know the occasional like just hard
crash straight to my phone desktop I'm I
think that's just server load and
that'll sort of just like even out over
time the the google thing on iOS there
that was a lot more serious and it's
great that they've actually patched that
out because you know they were allowing
basically full access to your do to your
Google profile but it seems that you
know hopefully I mean they've already
delayed some of the rollout for the rest
of world just to make sure that you know
like there's more stability in the
markets that is currently out any and
just look at World of Warcraft which is
hands down the most popular the biggest
MMO still every time they launch it's a
bit of a mess and it used to be huge
mess like an unplayable just throw out
there but but you still play it like
it's still fun it's still amazing and I
get the same thing with pokemon it's
frustrated as I get as soon as I like
I'll still like well you know I'll try
it I'll pick up the phone and then
there's a Pikachu my colleague am
there's Pikachu I'm back in I'm gonna
keep playing you got me got me 90 and
and this is the amazing thing about this
game right that we are sup like we're
okay to suffer through all of the all
the glitches right like you know I've
been playing it for a couple of weeks
now because we were in the beta and it
was still buggy it was worse than the
big it was worse than the beta right but
I'm sticking with it right and you know
imagine any other game company coming
out with a huge game like this and
having the server issue the problems
that it's having I mean it would just be
laughed out of the room right but you
know because i think it just really sort
of points of that affinity that we all
have towards pokemon and the franchise
are willing to forgive you know all the
hiccups the game is that sofa so do you
think it has staying power 90 days from
now you think they're still going to be
a bunch of folks at the sandwich shop
waiting to battle in line while they
wait for their turkey sandwiches no no
but I think it'll have a pretty strong
following still so you know a lot of the
you know more casual people will drop
out i think within a couple of weeks
right but they're still gonna be that
sort of really sort of big core that
will you know that will stick with this
game and try and get it and you know the
potential for this game is really
exciting we already talked about you
know how do you catch legendaries you
know what happens when trading starts
you know what happens when they add more
pokemon from you know the new generation
of new generations and I mean you know
for a poke
on fan you know there's nothing but sort
of upside to this game right now so it's
not going to be as big as it is now but
it's still going to be pretty big i
think pretty exciting augmented reality
games pokemon go really making a splash
in a big way I'll be interested to see
how it turns out